'How you doing, Bernardino?'
Now, some folks down
at the Piggly Wiggly
in the produce section,
real upset.
- You've been there?
- They're upset.
- Yeah.
- You've been there?
(Junior)
'Did you see anything while
you were down there?'
I'm...
I haven't been there for...
...seventy years?
- Seventy years?
- Oh.
Yeah. I mean,
I haven't been there for...
I mean, I was there
seventy years ago, I guess.
You were there at the
Piggly Wiggly seventy years ago?
Yeah. So it's been a while.
Yeah, that's a long time.
4:20 this afternoon.
Think hard. Produce section.
Area with fruits and vegetables.
A gentleman, Caucasian
about 5'10", roller skates
which made us think...
Maybe it's Terry.
Maybe Terry
would know this guy.
Maybe the person that works
there is stupid and ugly.
See, it seems,
again to me like you might
know this person
in the produce section.
I feel like it's coming back.
I don't know any fat women with
red hair in the produce section.
Alright, so this is
starting to fall into place.
- Our witness, Kelly O'Brien--
- She sounds like a bitch.
She was a little thick,
and she wasn't super nice.
- She wasn't super nice.
- That's true.
But maybe you
got off on the wrong foot
because what were you doing
in the produce section?
I was trying fruit on.
Mm-hmm.
That's exactly what we got.
- Oh, [bleep]. God!
- You see?
Let him go. Let him go.
(Junior)
'I didn't think
you could skate on grass.'
'Look at that
son of a bitch go.'